hey what is up guys mkbhd here and these
are my quick first impressions of the
newly announced lg g4 so i got to go to
the announcement in new york today and
at that event we got all the details and
everything we need to know and this is
the phone it looks a lot like the g flex
2 and it's moved on from the thinner
bezels and the design of last year's g3
but so first of all the design has a
slight curve to it yes it doesn't flex
but yes the display glass is actually
slightly curved in a way that you'll
notice and the build materials are
actually kind of interesting here as
well so holding it up it's a pretty
lightweight phone you know not too big
fits in the hand well with the curve and
it has metal sides which are glossy but
do give you something to grip on and
then it has this plastic back with a
diamond pattern uh not the best feeling
material in the world but there are some
other options so there's a ceramic
backed version which has white and
glossy and actually felt a bit heavier
to me at the event and then there is the
leather backed versions that we see
everywhere already
different colors of leather get you
different textures i tried to get a look
at basically all of them at the new york
event but i think the one i like the
best is just the black leather pretty
plain but it has a pretty smooth finish
too the only weird part is of course
that seam right up the middle the
stitched seam it doesn't serve any
functional purpose at all it's just a
hand-stitched looking seam right down
the middle of the phone got to decide if
you like that or not not sure if these
leather backed versions might cost extra
but i say that because if you took a
look at the little notch on the side of
the phone this is one of those traits
that makes this g4 a bit of a rare breed
it does still have a removable back a
removable 3 000 milliamp hour battery
and expandable storage via a micro sd
card slot so this is becoming less and
less common and it might just be one of
the last major flagships to have both of
those things either way with this
battery you get wireless charging but no
quick charging so it will be easier to
just pick up an extra battery and swap
them but during my testing i'll have to
figure out if this is exactly what you
want to do
in the full review we'll know exactly
how good the battery life is so anyway
the main new focus points of this phone
are the display and the camera the
display is awesome it's a 5.5 inch ips
quantum display and without getting too
technical here before the full review
basically it looks amazing it's quad hd
again it's super bright visible outdoors
very colorful very contrasty and very
very sharp
in real world use this is going to blow
plenty of people's minds just from my
first impressions i'll go ahead and put
this right up there in the top five
displays on any smartphone right now it
was that good looking to me and then the
other focus is like i said is the new
camera lg spent a lot of time talking
about all the features of this camera
and how it can literally be a dslr
replacement so they can talk the talk
but can this camera walk the walk well a
lot of the sample photos i looked at
looked really good but i mean they
always do so i tried to take a few
myself and i gotta say from the limited
testing i've done the photos did look
really good very sharp and pretty good
colors and dynamic range and everything
so i'm impressed so far with the geforce
camera the specs suggest it should be
amazing right so wide open f 1.8 maximum
aperture 16 megapixel 1 over 2.6 inch
sensor 3-axis optical image
stabilization laser autofocus and even a
new sensor on the back called a color
spectrum sensor which to put it simply
will help to better calculate white
balance so the laser autofocus was
extremely fast for me and it should be
so you got lasers determining how far
the focus is you got a new sensor to
measure the white balance this camera
was really quick and they've actually
added a double tap to the volume down
button on the back while your screen is
off which opens the camera app in under
a second and snaps a picture so now all
this speed and everything is coming from
you know these top-notch specs a
snapdragon 808 not the 810 uh three
gigabytes of ram and everything else on
paper is loaded up as you would expect
so it should handle all these pixels
better than the g3 did and perform
really well it's actually running
android 5.1 with lg's ux 4.0 on top and
you know what i'm pretty excited to get
to testing this phone it's got a couple
of new features i like uh go ahead and
let me know what you want to see tested
for the full review down in the comments
section right below that like button and
i will get to testing i already know i
want to see the battery life we want to
see if the camera is as impressive as it
claims to be but then there's a bunch
more questions that people have that
i'll try to answer so this is your
chance to get that in
and we'll see how good this looks thanks
for watching these first impressions and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace